>>> WE'RE GETTING INFORMATN
INTO OUR NEWSROOM THAT ATTORNEYS
FOR DONALD TRUMP OPPOSE THE TWO
CANDIDATES THAT THE DOJ PROPOSED
TO BE SPECIAL MASTER.
THEY'RE DECLINING TO GIVE
REASONS FOR THEIR OBJECTION.
>> LET'S GO TO JENNIFER RODGERS
A FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR AND
CNN ILLEGAL ANALYST.
WE'VE GOT KAITLAN.
>> AND JENNIFER RODGERS.
>> KAITLAN, WITH THE REPORTING,
WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>> TODAY, THE TRUMP LEGAL TEAM
IS COMING INTO COURT AND STILL
MAINTAINING THE BROAD VIEW THAT
DONALD TRUMP KEEPS POWER OVER
HIS RECORDS FROM HIS
ADMINISTRATION EVEN AFTER HE
LEAVES THE PRESIDENCY.
SPECIFICALLY IN A NEW COURT
FILING TODAY DONALD TRUMP'S
LAWYERS SAY HE HAS AN ABSOLUTE
RIGHT OF ACCESS TO DOCUMENTS
EVEN NOW WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
CLASSIFIED, WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WERE APPROPRIATELY BEING KEPT AT
MAR-A-LAGO AFTER THE PRESIDENCY.
THESE ARE BOLD LEGAL ARGUMENTS.
THE FILING TODAY IS ABOUT
DOWNPLAYING THE ALARMISM THAT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS EXPRESSED
IN COURT ABOUT NATIONAL SECURITY
DOCUMENTS THAT THEY NOW HAVE IN
THE GOVERNMENT'S HANDS AND AS
TRUMP DOES IN COURT HE'S
CONTINUING TO TRY TO SLOW THINGS
DOWN.
TRUMP'S REQUEST HERE TODAY IS
ASKING FOR HIS TEAM TO REVIEW
THE SEIZED CLASSIFIED RECORDS
ALONG WITH A THIRD-PARTY
APPOINTEE A SPECIAL MASTER.
WE'VE HEARD THIS BEFORE.
ALL OF THIS WOULD PUT ON HOLD
THE CRIMINAL PROBE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS PURSUING.
WE KNOW LAST WEEK, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WANTS TO MOVE QUICKLY
AND WORK THROUGH THE SUBSET OF
MORE THAN 100 DOCUMENTS MARKED
AS CLASSIFIED THAT THEY REMOVED
FROM MAR-A-LAGO LAST MONTH.
SO THIS IS THE LATEST REQUEST
ABOUT TIMING AND IT'S ABOUT WHO
CAN SEE THESE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, YET THE JUDGE HASN'T
RESPONDED TO THIS PARTICULAR
BACK AND FORTH YET.
>> KAITLAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR EXPLAINING ALL OF YOUR NEW
REPORTING FOR US.
LET'S BRING IN JENNIFER RODGERS
NOW.
SO BIG SHOCKER, THAT DONALD
TRUMP'S TEAM DOESN'T LIKE THE
PROPOSED SPECIAL MASTER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I COULD HAVE SEEN THAT COMING.
BUT HERE'S MY QUESTION, I
UNDERSTAND THEY WANT TO FREEZE
THE CRIMINAL PROBE.
WHAT ABOUT THE NATIONAL SECURITY
DAMAGE ASSESSMENT.
WOULD ANY DUJ OUT THERE,
JENNIFER -- JUDGE OUT THERE,
JENNIFER, STOP THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ASSESSMENT?
THE THOUGHT IS THAT PEOPLE
AROUND THE COUNTRY -- I MEAN
AROUND THE WORLD COULD BE IN
DANGER BECAUSE OF ALL OF THIS
>> THE ANSWER IS NO.
NO JUDGE WOULD STOP IT.
JUDGE CANNON ALREADY ALLOWED FOR
THAT, RIGHT.
SHE ALREADY SAID, YOU CAN USE IT
AS FAR AS THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ASSESSMENT GOES.
YOU CAN'T USE IT FOR THE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS DOJ CAME BACK
AND SAID WE CAN'T SEPARATE OUT
THOSE TWO BECAUSE WE NEED THE
FBI TO HELP US FIGURE OUT
WHETHER THERE'S ANY DAMAGE HERE.
SO NOW THEY SAID JUDGE, YOU HAVE
TO LET US DO THIS SIDE TO DO THE
OTHER SIDE AND THE QUESTION IS,
WHAT DOES SHE SAY TO THAT?
>> ON THE NEW REPORTING YOU'VE
GOT THE TWO PROPOSALS AND NAMES
PRESENTED FROM THE DOJ, TWO FROM
THE TRUMP TEAM.
TRUMP SAYS WE DON'T LIKE THE DOJ
PROPOSED.
DOES ONE TEAM'S SELECTION HAVE
MORE WEIGHT THAN THE OTHER?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THE
NOTION THAT TEAM TRUMP DOESN'T
WANT TO OFFEND ANYONE OR DAMAGE
ANYONE'S REPUTATION BY MAKING A
PUBLIC FILING IS SILLY.
I HOPE AND ASSUME THE JUDGE WILL
NOT ALLOW THEM TO MAKE A SEALED
FILING AS A MATTER OF GREAT
PUBLIC INTEREST AND YOU HOW SHE
CHOOSES THE SPECIAL MASTER IS
IMPORTANT TO YOUR POINT.
IT NEEDS TO BE TRANSPARENT.
THEY CAN MAKE ARGUMENTS FOR WHO
THEY THINK IT SHOULD BE.
THE JUDGE WILL CHOOSE.
THREE OF THE FOUR ARE THE TYPES
OF CANDIDATES YOU WOULD THINK
WOULD BE IN THE MIX NORMALLY,
FORMER FEDERAL JUDGES AND THAT
SORT OF THING.
SHE HAS QUALIFIED PEOPLE TO
CHOOSE FROM.
I SUSPECT GIVEN WHAT SHE'S DONE
TO DATE SHE WILL GO WITH ONE OF
THE TEAM TRUMP FOLKS TO SAY ONCE
AGAIN SHE'S GIVEN HIM ALL THE
PROCEDURE AND, YOU KNOW, ALL OF
THE --
>> SHE COULD CHOOSE A FIFTH
PERSON NOT ON THE LIST.
>> SHE COULD, BUT I SUSPECT SHE
WON'T.
I DON'T KNOW WHO SHE WOULD TURN
TO AND THESE PEOPLE HAVE, YOU
KNOW, THEY PUT FORWARD QUALIFIED
NAMES.
>> I WANT TO MOVE ON TO ANOTHER
ISSUE AND THAT IS THAT GEOFFREY
BERMAN, THE FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY
FOR THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW
YORK, IS TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESSURE THAT HE AND HIS OFFICE
WERE UNDER FROM THE DOJ UNDER
DONALD TRUMP TO PROSECUTE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
WE DIDN'T KNOW, REALLY, HOW THE
LENGTHS THAT TEAM TRUMP WAS
GOING TO GO TO GET SOME OF HIS
POLITICAL ENEMIES.
SUCH AS JOHN KERRY.
HERE IS WHAT GEOFFREY BERMAN IN
HIS NEW BOOK SAID THIS MORNING.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ATTACKS JOHN
KERRY IN TWO TWEETS SAYING THAT
KERRY ENGAGED IN POSSIBLE
ILLEGAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
IRANIAN OFFICIALS REGARDING THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
THE VERY NEXT DAY THE TRUMP
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT REFERS THE
JOHN KERRY CRIMINAL CASE TO THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
TWO TWEETS BY THE PRESIDENT AND
THE JOHN KERRY CRIMINAL CASE
BECOMES A PRIORITY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND THE STATUTE THEY WANTED US
TO USE WAS ENACTED IN 1799 AND
HAD NEVER BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
PROSECUTED.
>> WHAT CAN YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> YEAH.
SO IT'S INCREDIBLY DISAPPOINTING
TO THOSE OF US AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO SEE WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT UNDER
DONALD TRUMP AND BILL BARR.
BILL BARR CLAIMED HE DIDN'T READ
THE PRESIDENTS TWEETS AND THIS
SEEMS TO SUGGEST THE CONTRARY.
WE KNEW THEY TRIED TO INFLUENCE
WHAT OTHERS WERE DOING AROUND
THE COUNTRY IN TERMS OF CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS.
FAMOUSLY IN SOME INSTANCES LIKE
ROGER STONE.
THE NOTION YOU SHOULD PROSECUTE
THIS PERSON AND BILL BARR AND
HIS FOLKS WOULD SEND A REFERRAL
YOU SHOULD PROSECUTE THIS
PERSON, JOHN KERRY AND THE GREG
CRAIG CASE THEY TRIED TO
INTERFERE IT GOES AGAINST
EVERYTHING THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE